j'ai toujours aimé tout ce qui gravite
autour de la science fiction
que ce soit
les voyages interstellaires les
magnifiques ville où la vie semble plus
simple le confort plus accessible à tout
le monde des petits robots qui nous
aident dans le travail qui nous
facilitent la vie qui sont capables
d'interagir comme nous êtres humains je
trouvais ça beau phone vous connaissez
probablement d'élite à l'android la
série culte star trek d'android qui
comprenait tout sauf l'humour
je trouve ça bien qt alors juste comme
ça là j'aimerais savoir à main levée
combien de personnes pensent que dans un
futur proche
il y aura réellement des robots qui sont
capables de comprendre le langage humain
et d'interagir comme des humains pas
pire pas fixé bon ça mais quand même des
sceptiques
1 j'aimerais ça vous montrer une petite
vidéo qui peut-être va vous faire
changer d'avis et je parle des
sceptiques
c'est fait singstar bon comme vous le
voyez il ya quand même une amélioration
il ya un peu d'humour quand même ce que
vous voyez en fait c'est pas un
prototype dans un laboratoire c'est pas
un jouet c'est pas juste une poupée qui
bouge c'est réellement un vrai robot
c'est une vraie compagnie qui essayent
de vendre ça et c'est ce que vous allez
retrouver dans pas très longtemps dans
des kiosques d'information à l'aéroport
dans des centres d'achat donc on n'est
vraiment pas loin du tout d'avoir ce
type de technologie alors il ya plus de
15 ans maintenant j'avais commencé un
doctorat dans ce qu'on appelle le
traitement automatique du langage
naturel dans l'objectif de comprendre
les conversations humaines de manière
automatique donc on parle on jase mais
comment est-ce qu'on peut permettre à la
machine de comprendre ce qu'on dit puis
une fois qu'on l'a compris qu est ce que
la machine peut faire un retour
puis ce que j'avais fait bien j'avais
donc fait mon doctorat là dessus c'est
sûr que mes parents capote est aisée
mais l'art qu'est ce que tu vas faire
avec ça peut te trouve un job avec ça
mais j'ai quand même réussi à travailler
quelques années dans la recherche dans
différentes universités puis quelques
années plus tard j'ai travaillé au crime
inquiétez-vous porte c'est le centre de
recherche informatique de montréal
j'étais pas encore rendu délinquante
filles mes parents était super content
j'avais une job j'avais un salaire few
là tout était beau et en travaillant au
crime j'avais eu l'occasion vraiment de
rencontrer plusieurs entreprises de voix
en fait ce qu'on pouvait faire avec
l'intelligence artificielle pour
répondre à des besoins réels de la vie
et c'est comme ça que je me suis dit ben
en fait je pense que j'ai vraiment tout
pour essayer moi aussi de confronter
tout ce que j'ai appris à résoudre des
problèmes réels
et c'est comme ça que j'ai partie ma
compagnie avec mon associé charles
olivier tous les deux passionnés
d'intelligence artificielle ben on a
commencé à travailler à essayer de
résoudre des problèmes dont celui que
aujourd'hui on fait dans la compagnie
qui permet en fait de fournir une
solution pour les entreprises pour avec
par les aider à rendre leurs clients
plus heureux donc si on était capable
aujourd'hui de comprendre tout ce que
disaient les clients via leurs textos
avait dit à leurs courriels sur facebook
sur twitter et qu'on était capable de
synthétiser tout ça et dire finalement à
la compagnie bas et regarde pas ce qui
était client et ne sont pas contents de
ce produit sur tel aspect il ya des
choses à améliorer vous imaginez à quel
point et nous en tant qu on sait moins
consommateur on serait heureux c'est ça
qu'on essaye de résoudre avec avec notre
produit
alors c'est sûr que ce que j'ai fait
comme tout bon entrepreneur j'ai
commencé à lire des tonnes et des tonnes
de livres sur comment créer une
entreprise
les parties difficiles les pièges à
éviter toutes sortes de choses mais avec
le recul
quelques années maintenant je me suis
rendu compte que en réalité avec quand
on voit un produit qui contient de
l'intelligence artificielle ben il ya
comme une un degré de complexité
additionnel qui fait que l'entreprise
devient tout petit peu plus périlleuses
plus complexe il ya d'autres pièges
typique à l'intelligence artificielle
qu'il faut essayer d'éviter et c'est un
peu de ça que j'ai envie de vous parler
donc quand on passe à la
commercialisation de ce type de
technologie qu'est ce qu'on veut éviter
mais commençons par le début par le
commencement qu'est ce que
l'intelligence artificielle mais
l'intelligence artificielle c'est le
processus et c'est la capacité de
reproduire le raisonnement humain ce
processus cognitifs qui qui est inclus
dans une décision dans nos prédictions
donc finalement nous comment qu'on
réfléchisse et ça ça veut dire quoi ça
veut dire qu' il ya quelque chose qui se
passe qui fait appel
à des connaissances et c'est ça un peu
la complexité qu'on va retrouver avec
l'intelligence artificielle nous en tant
qu'être humain on a plein de
connaissances on utilise pleins de
connaissances qu'on a acquéri de notre
vécu de nos études mais ça se fait dans
le temps donc comment est-ce qu'on peut
permettre à la machine de faire ça
rapidement et avoir toute la halle la
connaissance en fait nécessaires à la
prise de décision
c'est ça qui c'est ça qui fait que c'est
difficile c'est ça qui rend cette
technologie quand même relativement plus
complexe que la technologie standard
j'irai en a tellement entêtement pardon
aux technologies de l'information
alors pour répondre à sept complices
complexité il ya une solution qui cette
solution c'est l'apprentissage
automatique
donc c'est quoi l'apprentissage
automatique maria l'itc un algorithme
qui a la capacité de d'apprendre un
schéma général un schéma global à partir
de beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de données
qui décrivent cette ce schéma là mais de
manière individuelle donc si on prend
par exemple la reconnaissance faciale
donc maintenant il ya plein de systèmes
qui sont capables de reconnaître une
personne de manière générale par rapport
à un animal un chien ou un chat
comment ça se fait ça en réalité on va
donner à l'algorithme des milliers voire
des millions d'image de personnes puis
cet algorithme il va apprendre à
reconnaître des traits globo qui font
qu'ils sont distinctif par rapport à
l'animal et c'est vraiment ça qui fait
que l'algorithme voix apprendre à
reconnaître le visage d'un être humain
mais évidemment quand on parle de
beaucoup de données on va se dire ok
mais on va aller les chercher où ces
données balle on est chanceux depuis une
décennie à peu près où vous entendez
beaucoup parlé du terme big data donc
c'est quoi ces c'est des millions de
données sur tout et n'importe quoi
puis grâce à l'avènement ou ou la face
la facilité d'accès à la capacité de
stockage et de calcul
maintenant c'est accessible à peu près à
n'importe qui n'importe quelle compagnie
peut avoir accès
à ses capacités de calcul et la capacité
de stocker beaucoup de données vous
connaissez les compagnies comme amazon
google microsoft tous les genres et
toutes ces compagnies là aujourd'hui
ils offrent ce type d'infrastructure à
des coups tout simplement dérisoire et
ça ça a aidé vraiment s'adonner à un
super coup de pouce à la recherche en
intelligence artificielle parce que
subitement les gens pouvaient ramasser
des données vous voulez pouvait
améliorer les algorithmes et donc passer
plus rapidement avoir une meilleure
maturité est passé à la
commercialisation et donc c'est ça que
je veux un peu élaborée là dessus donc
au delà de la complexité je dirais
scientifique de l'intelligence
artificielle
quand on passe au niveau de
commercialisation via une nouvelle
complexité une autre couche qui
s'additionne à ça puis 1
il ya à peu près trois éléments que je
vais que j'aimerais dont j'aimerais vous
parler puis le premier c'est clairement
d'éviter d'avoir un tweet technologique
autrement dit en tant que scientifique
on peut très rapidement partir sur un
projet ambitieux qui résout le problème
un problème universel et on peut y
passer sa vie pillon ça n'aboutira nulle
part il se sera jamais commercialisé
donc une première chose c'est vraiment
focus et sur un as un problème bien
particulier et pourquoi c'est important
c'est parce que comme je le disais tout
à l'heure quand il quelque chose qui
touche au raisonnement humain aux
connaissances ben si on a besoin de
beaucoup de connaissances c'est
difficile prenons le cas d'un système
qui fait de la dictée automatique
si on était pour développer ce système
dans le domaine médical ben il faudrait
juste apprendre le vocabulaire médical
mais si on voulait vendre un système qui
permettait de faire la dictée pour
monsieur tout le monde
ce serait le domaine médical ce serait
les finances sera l'hôtellerie serait
une multitude de domaines qui fait que
c'est vraiment difficile de mettre toute
cette information là dans ce système est
la solution à ça c'est assez simple
c'est que d'essayer de trouver une
compagnie qui serait en fait qui
vivraient un problème en particules
et que l'intelligence pourrait résoudre
et essayer de travailler ensemble donc
d'une part ça va permettre d'avoir de
l'information et deuxièmement ça va
permettre à notre élément très important
c'est de récupérer le feedback de nos
futurs clients
encore une fois évité le trip
technologique c'est aussi savoir qu'est
ce qui aide le client puis qu'est-ce qui
ne l'est elle ne les aide pas et ça ça
m'amène au deuxième point le deuxième
élément c'est de pouvoir expliquer ce qu
apporte l'intelligence artificielle
pourquoi pourquoi moi en tant que
personne qui vos clients qui va acheter
une technologie je vais aller chercher
je vais je vais vouloir acheter votre
technologie parce qu'elle l'intelligence
artificielle est en réalité très souvent
ce qu'on va retrouver dans le marché
c'est c'est de la technologie qu'ils ont
un problème
et quand nous on arrive avec une
nouvelle technologie qui inclut
l'intelligence artificielle j'en avais
déjà des solutions
pourquoi la mienne serez meilleurs donc
il ya tout un tout une notion de
sensibilisation pourquoi celle-ci en
particulier qui contient une
intelligence artificielle voit être
meilleur et pour ça encore une fois il
ya plusieurs éléments y ait plusieurs
stratégies un c'est de pouvoir démontrer
l'apport de ce type de technologie le
deuxième élément c'est permettre un peu
de montrer d'autres cas d'utilisation de
l'intelligence artificielle et comment
que ça améliore réellement les choses
aujourd'hui on va avoir des systèmes qui
sont dans le domaine médical qui sont
dans le commerce il ya plusieurs vous
regardez amazon va en arrière il ya
aussi des algorithmes d'intelligence qui
vous aiguiller sur d'autres produits qui
que vous allez aimer parce que vous avez
acheté un autre produit particulier donc
c'est un peu faire ce parallèle et bâtir
sur sur ce succès l'an le troisième
élément est qui et pas le moindre je
dirais c'est celui de la promesse qu'on
fait à nos clients quand on leur vend
delà ce type de technologie nous en tant
qu'être humain on est très souvent on
fonctionne très souvent en binaire
inquiet est ce que ça marche ça marche
ça marche pas c'est l'un des deux ça
marche à peu près
c'est pas le bon message qu'on veut dire
un autre client mais pourtant c'est la
réalité
n'oublions pas on est en train de
reproduire un raisonnement humain puis
même nous en tant qu'être humain bas on
se trompe on est on entend les mêmes
faits mais chacun va réagir
on va répondre une réponse différente de
l'autre et on peut se tromper
donc c'est normal que aussi en tant que
produit y est ainsi une certaine marge
d'erreur y ait une certaine un certain
niveau d'erreur est donc à ce moment là
il s'agit surtout de gérer la tente du
client comment est ce qu'on peut lui
expliquer donc qui peut y avoir de
l'erreur puis pour le rassurer aussi lui
montrer qu'on a la capacité la
possibilité de lui permettre de corriger
le système
donc il ya vraiment c'est tout un
paradigme qui va changer et qu'il faut
vraiment prendre le temps et faire les
choses pour qu'ils comprennent et il les
mettre en confiance à quelque part donc
ce sont vraiment ce type de défi je vous
dirais qu'ils sont des choses qui
s'additionnent déjà à la complexité
qu'on va avoir quand on crée une
nouvelle une nouvelle entreprise
alors est ce que ça veut dire que le
taux de je dirais de deux succès est
moins bon pour les entreprises qui
utilisent la télé l'intelligence
artificielle que d'autres entreprises
clairement non je vous dirais même
depuis 2011 il ya encore beaucoup plus
de compagnies qui font d'intelligence
artificielle en fait qui vend des
produits avec une forte composante qui
utilisent intelligence artificielle et
avec ça ça va tellement bien pour ce
type de technologiques aussi les
investisseurs ont commencé à investir
beaucoup plus dans ce type de
technologie donc c'est bon ça se passe
bien je pense que la révolution de
l'intelligence artificielle a commencé
puis elle est là pour rester c'est sûr
que si ça amène d'autres défis que je
mettrai plus comme des défis
socio-économiques
juste pour vous donner une idée
depuis 2015 il ya une initiative qui est
conduit par plusieurs pays les etats
unis le canada puis d'autres pays en
europe pour justement réfléchir sur
l'impact
quel est l'impact de cette révolution de
l'intelligence artificielle est ce que
on a réellement des robots qui vont nous
prendre notre place nous en tant qu'être
humain au niveau du travail
est ce que la notion sociale d'interagir
entre les personnes va être différente
est ce que demain on aura des amis qui
seraient des robots donc c'est toutes
sortes de débats vraiment qu'ils les
gens vraiment se mettre du temps à
réfléchir là dessus puis je peux vous
dire que c'est assez sérieux pour pour
conduire l'initiative cette initiative
sur une durée du d'un siècle
donc ça a commencé en 2015 ça va finir
en 1115 c'est quand même c'est quand
même assez majeur et je peux vous dire
aussi que j'ai pas nécessairement la
réponse à cette question là et quel sera
l'impact est ce que ça veut dire que
demain matin on va avoir la moitié de la
population au chômage qui aura plus de
travail pour les gens je ne pense pas
personnellement mais je pense que la
réponse voit surtout venir au fur et à
mesure du futur puis cc nous en tant
qu'être humain puis comment qu'on
s'ajuste convoi qui voit qui allons
permettre de construire cette cette
réponse à ça fait que je vous laisse
avec avec cette question là et puis on
aura le temps tout à l'heure de jaser de
sa merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]